hi I'm Samantha brown hi I'm Holly
Williams I'm Rachel my name is Enoch and
Rachel's little brother and I have come
to some unique properties versus is
special for me personally I just want to
be able to become financially free you
get awesome knowledge in making better
decisions when it comes to these
properties there are specific tactics
that Sam I know using that I want to
learn like a lease option agreement how
to buy properties that I give you a
money good return for my money and how
to set up a promote my property laws are
very similar to Rachel's to gain a few
houses a few properties within the next
12 months so I'd love to get into the
position where I can be financially free
through property to have the security
that property offers would be fantastic
I've done pasta courses in the past and
sometimes we walk away feeling a bit you
don't know exactly what to do you know
you've got this big idea with a strategy
but you don't know what steps to take
next I can't wait to meet your needs
we're just going in reeling with an open
mind just hoping to grab as much as we
can
I'm really looking forward to the day
I've seen little clips from his courses
on YouTube before and they look really
exciting a literary high-energy and
looks like you learn a lot as well I'm
really excited to get started and just
click it in there and nothing
[Music]
so we've just met Samuel who's told us a
little bit about his journey and how he
got to where he's got to and we kind of
introduced ourselves we met a bunch of
the other people in the room I like how
he started the program with telling us
about himself asking about what we would
like and that kind of thing so he he
gets to know us we get to know him so no
stronger title of the course around what
it is that we want to do a lot about
so no our session Samuel girl has laptop
and he found deals right there in front
of us he called the agents who were
after take an offer below market value
and look to the rent and actually
working out return on investment so
especially and sitting in the numbers
and finding a value at the end which
totally blew my mind I'm from the south
there are some real amazing bargains up
north so I'm just really excited to go
and do that myself and see what I can
find
compared to the other trainings we've
been on - it's so different the
practicality makes it much easier for
you to step through because with one
training you have they just gave you
like it so far for PowerPoint and I was
there and then you that's when you think
oh my goodness oh I don't think I can do
this but then when he goes through it
like I go save you this is my sleep it's
just quite empowering as well we're
trying to find a house and check out the
value it and then get the rent so once
we found out the price and the rents
will calculate the return on investment
and try and come up with something over
20% of hopefully more like 25 we've only
been searching for we only been
searching for a couple of minutes and
already we found something which is
looking pretty good so I think we'll
find something with Samuel as well
pretty coming on this course I I've
looked through white news and everybody
I speak to says that you need to find
things off market and no one else knows
about them and yes secret and someone I
thought there's no way especially live
in front of people that you can find a
deal that's worth investing in and I'm
just shocked that you can and actually
it's not that hard you just need to know
what you're looking at and you know have
the steps and follow the steps it's that
simple in such a short time and 14
minutes there's money to find one and
also find them their findings to be
about 23 percent so I'm really happy
with that yeah I've just come out of the
evening HMO session it's long day
there's so much information so seeing
Samuel do it up on big screen and then
everybody else getting the chance to
work it all out in little groups and a
bit of competition to come up with the
best return on investment and of course
I thought I had the best return on
investment and when I got on stage to
just show an odd mist of picture of a
really awful horrible bathroom which was
a really amazing end up so it was all
good and but there were some some great
deals that
finding in a session so I have no doubt
that we're all going to go away and not
sleep tonight and instead researching
white move today is the second day of
the course yesterday was really really
good we learned how to accurately
calculate the return on investment for a
property yesterday was really
interesting and I opened it it gave me
more confidence to believe that I can
actually start my own thing in the next
couple of months hopefully you can top
it
no pressure there on a train back home I
ended up looking for deals and we found
another house and we found out the ROI
and we found it was there about 26
percent I thought this is crazy I mean
we can do in their in their trains
journey when we have a month or two
months I just shows you that what we can
achieve is crazy so we hadn't been here
would have making those sort of
estimations dose or values on feelings
not on formulas and so I think just
being here letting herself to us today
we're gonna learn how to invest in
property without using any of our own
money which is really exciting because
obviously even if you've got capital to
invest at some point it's gonna run out
how to raise finance yeah thanks I think
that's going to be the kick in the
backside that we need there yes
finding that finance I I think it's
gonna be hard getting out of your
comfort zone and get comfortable with
being uncomfortable I think it's great
how we're not just sat in the room
listening to Samuel speak he gets us up
on our feet finding deals calling agents
looking at right moves speaking to other
people networking it feels really
interactive and that's a lot of fun I've
just learned about lease option
agreements and the exact words to say
when speaking to somebody who might be a
potential candidate for
in agreement and I've never had anyone
tell me the words to say before like the
actual sentences the the way to explain
it making sure that you're absolutely
helping something out in the best way
possible to making sure that they are in
time and happy and that there's no way
they're gonna have remorse afterwards
because you've gone through all the
options with them so Samuel told us that
this afternoon we're going to be doing a
roleplay exercise where we actually try
and get hold of a lease option agreement
property ourselves so we'll be in pairs
I'd imagine and going through and trying
to work out exactly the best way to
speak to these sellers I'm actually
really impressed with the course overall
it's just been amazing the detail is
fantastic and all the people around that
I've been talking to have been wonderful
as well so it's been a great session so
far it's not addressed today and we're
kicking off the next session in about 20
seconds
so I've done a lot of research into
property before I came in the course and
I wasn't really that confident in myself
but what was so great was that on the
course we got to sit down with a laptop
with our phone find deals Sammy will be
there so we could ask him any questions
we had so now I really feel like how the
confidence in my own knowledge and the
knowledge that Samuel has taught me to
go out and find these fine properties
and make that mine before coming here
I've really struggled with the concept
of Lease Option agreements and how to
actually convince people people who are
trying to sell their houses how to
convince them to take a lease option
agreement I've realized most of that is
actually in my head I've thought that
they wouldn't want to so I think my own
mindset blocks of some of them have been
changed by coming here I've just really
enjoyed myself really here and been
empowered been motivated and I've got
really been given the kick in the
backside read that I needed to just to
cut the world get myself moving and
start doing something get the ball
rolling
the final bit actually was thinking
about my 12 month plan and there's lots
there lots that I want to do so I'm
excited to go away and put things into
action and I'm gonna check in with sound
tell them how I've been
he was in minces words if it's black
it's black if it's white it's white if I
was to actually seek out a mentor in
investing
I would definitely seek him out now I'm
leaving the crash course I feel like
I've got the information the knowledge
to really pursue my property goals to
find some HMOs to find some lease option
agreements and really take the first
steps to becoming financially free
probably the most informative prophecy
course I've been on and I've been on a
few actual how to step by step guides
things to say with the most charismatic
trainer I have ever met honestly what
have you got to lose cut from your time
it's not that hard to get see whether
you come to Birmingham or London or
wherever all you're giving up is a
little bit of your time and think of the
possibilities interactive engaging and
intense knowledgeable and power in
practical life changing experience
informative intense super fun place it
when you attend the property investors
crash course life will never be the same
again as thousands and thousands of
people are experiencing here in the UK
from across the world
[Music]
you